the old harbor of nice one of the most
beautiful spots in the city on the Cote
d'Azur a few steps away down the rugged
Cocoa Beach is a small inconspicuous
restaurant a family operation for almost
80 years it bears the name of its
location Cocoa Beach it's hosted
illustrious guests for decades the
tsubame more people should just be able
to enjoy a good time here in pleasant
surroundings with food on that plate
food that has its natural flavors the
daunting IKEA every one of we lose this
election of fresh products is widen nice
open-air markets offer everything grown
in the countryside of Provence the
southern French city is also a paradise
for people who like fish and seafood
Coco Beach is so near the water that the
fishermen bring their catch here even
before they take it to the market hi
what do you have today
ah sea bass let's take a look at it yes
the eyes are still bright the gills are
red this is what really fresh fish looks
like oh sure
for decades Coco Beach has scarcely
changed the way it prepares sea bass
in the cell phone list crews on that we
prepare it as naturally as possible so
the true flavor isn't lost you don't add
oil or vinegar to high quality caviar
because you want it to natural taste
it's the same with sea bass with such a
wonderful product damn it
you shouldn't adulterate its flavor with
sauces the Gotthard fish is placed on
the charcoal grill just at the point
when it's producing the greatest heat it
should be grilled quite fast at a high
temperature office but not for too long
it should still be pink inside and it
mustn't be too dry meanwhile Phe lino
prepares the side dish slicing to
martha's and over jeans and placing them
on the grill beside the fish Quirino
tells us how to make the sea bass really
moist
Oris is iike you see but physically the
scales on it first because that protects
the meat of the fish yeah when you turn
the fish over the scales are burned okay
now you can't really remove them first
with a fork at Marley then with a little
brush which was so that the burn scars
don't attraction the flavor of the fish
degree apart on a lugubrious on
after about 20 minutes he removes the
fish and vegetables from the grill he
removes the bones then adds a little
salt and plenty of olive oil
among the customers at Cocoa Beach
grilled sea bass was always a favorite
dish and it still is act as I learned
her law in Tommy Schneider were regular
guests here and Pablo Picasso sometimes
paid his bill by spontaneously drawing
on it these drawings are now worth a
fortune he defeated the numbers on it to
see the diversity cerca de pusi yes he
used to celebrate his birthday with his
family and many friends our families
Ernie I think you just liked it here he
loved to spend a few pleasant hours here
with this view of nice the best humble
mom
and this is another way old cuisine can
look simple and classic enjoyed with
view of the Bay of nice